الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ايقاف اطلاق النار
سيكون هزيمه كبيره للعالم الغربي والكريم
لاند محادثه جدل قيمه لها ولن تنتهي الحرب
واشنطن تدفع بسلاح تحذر منهم موسكو لتفادي
الهزيمه فما الذي يجري واردوغان يدخل خطا
الازمه الاوكرانيه مجددا وبوتين يرحب
ومسيرات كياب تغزو السماء الروسيه والرد
الروسي لا يتاخر وزيلا سكيا من الاغتيال
بغرابه النيجر تقول كلمتها الاخيره للغرب
وايطاليا تتدخل تل ابيب تقترب بخبث من
الرياض وتركيا تحصل على اكبر عقد الدفاعيا
في تاريخها من السعوديه والصين توجه ضربه
للفلبين ومانيلا تطلق تحذيرا شديدا اللهجه
في وجه اصحاب العيون الضيقه الجيش
الامريكي يرسل سفونه بجيش قوامه 3000
جنديا للبحر الاحمر فما هو الهدف ما بعد
محادثات شده الحرب خرجت عن اطارها
والهزائم الغربيه تتوالى او دعونا نقول
الخسائر الغربيه تتواصل وعين الغرب ترمق
المبادره السعوديه بطرف خفي ليعلنها
مستشار مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني ميخائيل
بوتيلياك ان اي وقف لاطلاق النار في
اوكرانيا سيكون انتصارا لروسيا مضيفا ان
هذا سيكون هزيمه كبيره للعالم الغربي
ونهايه النظام الامني العالمي القائم ما
كل هذا الياس يا هذا ام ان لك مارب اخرى
ليجيب بودالياك بنفسه وفي ذات التصريح
بقوله ان ذلك يعني الحاجه الى المزيد من
الاسلحه والصواريخ والطائرات
متقول من الاول انك عايز سلاح لازمتها ايه
لف الطويله دي وهنا حدد وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني ديمتري كوليبا نوعيه السلاح
الذي تريده كياف بطلبها من واشنطن ان
تسلمها صواريخ اي تي اي سي ام وذلك في
حديث لكوليبا مع نظيره الامريكي
لمناقشه محادثات جدا كان مستشار الرئيس
الامريكي للامن القومي
قد اعلن في وقت السابق ان الرئيس الامريكي
امكانيه
الى ثلاثمائه لكن القرار النهائيا لم يتخذ
بعد لتورد تقارير وسائل اعلام امريكيه انا
واشنطن قريبه من اتخاذ القرار بشان تزويد
كييف بهذه الصواريخ لكن الاداره الامريكيه
لم تؤكد صحه هذه التقارير الرسميه بحسب
وكاله نوفوستي هذه الصواريخ التي تحذر
منها موسكو دائما فهل تغامر واشنطن
متجاهله للعواقب وعلى ذكر محادثه السعوديه
اكدت متحدثه بوتين ماريا الزخاروف ان
اجتماع جده حول اوكرانيا لا يحظى باي قيمه
له بمعزل عن مشاركه روسيا واخذ مصالحها في
الاعتبار اي ان لا قيمه للمحادثات التي
شاركت بها اكثر من اربعين دوله ان لم يتم
اشراك روسيا فهل وصلت الرساله الى كياف
حيث اعلن مكتب رئيس اوكرانيا
جهاز المحاكاه للتدرب على قياده مقاتلات
اف 16 الامريكيه من جمهوريه تشاك اعطوهم
اجهزه للتدريب على المقاتلات فمتى تاتي
هذه المقاتله اذا خصوصا وان الخسائر
الاوروبيه تزداد مع اطاله امد الحرب حيث
بلغت الخسائر المباشره لشركات الاوروبيه
اكثر من 100 مليار يورو وهذا فقط بسبب
انسحابها من السوق الروسيه منذ بدء الحرب
الاوكرانيه وذلك وفق صحيفه فاينانشون
تايمز البريطانيه التي حللت بيانات اكبر
الشركات الاوروبيه للعام ونصف العام
الماضي ميدانيا اعلن فياتش لادا كوف حاكم
مقاطعه الروسيه الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا
اسقاط طائره مسيره اوكرانيه اقتربت من
مدينه بينما تم تسجيل سقوط 65 قذيفه
اوكرانيه في انحاء مقاطعه خلال 24 ساعه
ممالحق اضرارا بمنزلين وخط للكهرباء هذا
واعلنت الدفاع الروسيه تقدم الجيش الروسي
على محور كوبيانسك بمقاطعه شرقيه اوكرانيا
وسد جميع هجمات قوتك على مختلف المحاور
والقضاء على اكثر من 600 جنديا اوكراني
ومع اعداد كهذا ها نحن نتصفح امامكم
المصدر في الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه
وبالعوده الى حرب مسيرات قال حاكم كالوجا
الروسيه ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي اسقطت
مسيره في سماء المقاطعه جنوب غرب موسكو من
جهته اعلن الجيش الروسي ان وحدات مجموعه
الغرب التابعه للجيش سيطرت على سبعه مواقع
تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه ودمرت سريه بوشاه
في
فيما قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه شنت هجمات بثلاثين صاروخا
ونفذت اثنتين وخمسين غاره جويه كما اطلقت
75 مقذوفا من راجمات الصواريخ خلال 24
ساعه اشارت الهيئه في بيان الى ان خطوط
المواجهه بين الطرفين شهدت 50 اشتباكا
ونفذ الطيران الاوكراني اربع عشره غاره
على مواقع القوات الروسيه وكالعاده اليكم
المصدر
الروسيه ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي اسقطت
مسيره في سماء المقاطعه جنوب غرب موسكو
فجر اليوم من جانبه اعلن الجيش الروسيا
وحدات مجموعه الغرب التابعه للجيش سيطرت
على سبعه مواقع تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه
ودمرت سريه مشاف في منطقه اولشان
يقابل كان الجيش الاوكراني قد قصف جسرين
يربطان مقاطعه خراسون بشبه جزيره
القمه وياتي هذا التطور بعد هجمات جويه
روسيه واسعه استهدف بعضها قواعد جويه
غربيه اوكرانيا يخرج الرئيس الاوكراني
فلادي مرزيلنسكي ويؤكد بان اوكرانيا تحقق
نتائج كبيره على الارض وارجع
الى انظمه الدفاع الامريكيه على الرغم من
عشرات الهجمات التي شنتها روسيا خلال
الاسبوع المنصرم وبين هذا وذاك كشفت
المخابرات الاوكرانيه انها افشلت مخططا
لاغتيال سيلينسكي وقال جهاز الامن
الاوكراني اسبيو انه احتجز مخبره الروسيه
على علاقه بالتحضير للضربه الروسيه كانت
ستستهدف الرئيس الاوكراني واضاف ان المخبر
كانت تجمع معلومات استخباراتيه حول زياره
عشيه الرحله الاخيره لرئيس اوكرانيا الى
منطقه ميكولايز
الاحداث والتطورات اعتبر رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلياهو انه يمكن لاسرائيل
والسعوديه العمل على تطوير العلاقات
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه حتى لو لم يتبادل
البلدان الاعتراف واشار نتنياهو لوكاله
بلومبرج الى انه يمكن لا والسعوديه انشاء
ممر اقتصادي يمر عبر شبه الجزيره العربيه
الى اوروبا يشمل الطاقه والنقل وتكنولوجيا
الاتصالات اعلنت الشركه السعوديه للصناعات
العسكريه سامي توقيعه اتفاقيه مع شركه
بايكار التركيه للصناعات الدفاعيه لتوطين
صناعه مسيره
ومكوناتها في السعوديه وتعد هذه الاتفاقيه
الموقعه بين الرياض وانقره لشراء طائرات
مسيره تركيه من شركه بايكار اكبر عقد
الدفاعي في تاريخ تركيا وفق وكاله رايترز
قال مسؤول فلبيني ان الحكومه الفلبينيه
استدعت السفير الصيني لنقل احتجاج
دبلوماسي على استخدام خفر السواحل الصينيه
خراطيم المياه ضد قاربه امداد فلبيني في
بحر الصين الجنوبي المتنازع عليه وكان خبر
السواحل الصيني قد اعلن طرد اربع سفن
فلبينيه انتهكت المياه الصينيه بمنطقه
الى انقلاب النيجر حيث اغلق المجلس
العسكري الح المجال الجوي للبلاد حتى
اشعار اخر من جهتها طلبت الخارجيه
الايطاليه مجموعه ايكواس بتمديد مهله
الممنوحه للمجلس العسكري في النيجر لتعلن
الايكوس عن قمه اخرى لاعضائها الخميس
المقبل قال الاسطول الخامس الامريكي ان
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف بحار وجنديا من مشاه
البحريه وصلوا الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط في
جزء من اجراءات معلن عنها مسبقا من وزاره
الدفاع واضاف الاسطول الخامس في بيان ان
سفينه هجوم برمائيه وسفينه انزال عبرت
قناه السويس في اتجاه البحر الاحمر لتوفير
اصول جويه وبحريه اضافيه
[موسيقى]